support all of you in other ways with
daily class schedules to kind of
approximate keep the learning going on
during the closer's webinars for
teachers and parents and also this
homeroom is really just a way to stay
connected talk to interesting people
about interesting topics and answer any
questions you have and so over the
course of this conversation and I have a
very exciting guest today I'll give a
proper introduction in a few minutes
encourage you to put any questions you
might have on Facebook or on YouTube and
our team is going to be looking at them
and getting to as many of them as
possible I will give my standard
announcement a Khan Academy just a
reminder is a not-for-profit we only
exist because of philanthropic donations
we were running at a deficit even before
the kovat crisis and you could imagine
now that our traffic our usage is almost
3x of what it typically is registrations
or 5 to 10 X of what they typically are
and we're trying to accelerate a bunch
of programs our costs have gone up even
higher and so if you're in a position to
do so please think about making a
donation I want to give a special shout
out to several corporations that have
stepped up in just the last few weeks to
help with this effort including Bank for
America AT&T Novartis fastly and
google.org
so thanks all of them and for our
longtime supporters obviously many
foundations and corporations but we did
we do need more help so if you can
please think about donating so with that
I'd like to introduce our next guest who
has actually been played a huge role in
Khan Academy even existing he's been a
supporter of Khan Academy from really
the early years george trepal Oh lemon
nice to see you George Apollo hi ru so
I'm doing all I'm doing all right and
you know I thought there's a lot of
interesting things for us to talk about
over the course of this Kover the course
of the next 30 minutes or so you've done
very well
from a business point of view you've
been a very active philanthropist I
think you have some very interesting
life stories we have some young a lot of
young people who watch this livestream
who are really just trying to figure out
how to navigate their own lives so maybe
that's a good place to start you know I
was reading some of your bio and
obviously we've known each other for
many years now but talk a little bit
about your early start you know it
sounds like you're a very good student
you are an amazing tennis player
and then you you got to college and it
sounds like you didn't have the you
weren't a you weren't a fish in water
initially hard times so I went to
college when I was very young 17 I had
never been to the United States before
and I was basically a surfer and a
tennis player and college was tough in
the beginning I wasn't used to studying
I wasn't used to reading so I was very
tough but I I made it through and and
adapting that first year was was one of
the many crises I sort of went through
in life I was making a list of all the
crises I've gone through in the last 80
years and I guess it started when I was
born five days before the Second World
War so but even when I was four or five
I remember to my family
listening to Bank voice of America and
finding out what was going on in the war
so every sort of eight to ten years
there is some sort of a crises that
comes up and you learn how to live with
them you learn how to adapt on each one
of the crises I think I've come out a
better informed person or a better
prepared person or like that this crises
were now undergoing is one of the
toughest ones but you know we'll make it
out of it and I'm trying to figure out
what are gonna be the learnings and how
could I come out of it better than I was
before so this is one more crises
actually no and that's a good way to
think about it and and you have more
experience to draw from than I do but it
does seem like it feels around roughly
every decade something comes up either
personally or or in the macro picture as
a whole but I want to double click on on
what you talked about your early life
because I think there's so many students
who even before the kovat crisis were
feeling a little bit long
they felt they feel a hunger to make
something out of their life have a
purpose but sometimes don't know what it
is how to discover it and then obviously
in times of crisis like now things can
get even more difficult so in those
early years as you mentioned you're
coming from Brazil you're you're a
freshman in Boston you didn't like the
weather you were having trouble getting
used to just even how things worked what
were you telling inside of your head or
what do you think it was the traits or
the muscles that you had that allowed
you to persevere through that and not
essentially give up well my my family
thought it was important I actually
wanted to quit Harvard and but you know
my family kept saying uh Harvard is so
important and get it done and get it
over with
etc and like that so after my first year
at Harvard where I flunked a lot of
courses and and almost got suspended him
like that I decided I am I made a very
stupid decision I decided I would go
back and I would finish the next three
years in two years so I sort of buckled
down took twice the number of courses I
should normally be taking and so I got
out of Harvard and I passed but I didn't
really learn as much as I could have
learned or how as much as I should have
learned I I was just there to get it
over and done with
etc and only later that had become that
it became clear to me how much more I
could have learned if I had taken more
time if I had socialized a bit more if I
had met a few more of the professor's
that were teaching the courses and
things like that and basically I was
there to get to get it done with him and
get out of there
and so it wasn't a good decision but
that's what happened and and so I got
out and and then I went to Europe to
work for for a bank in Europe
and I I worked there for about seven
months in this Bank and it was very very
boring and I always played a lot of
tennis and you know my all my
grandparents are Swiss my parents just
was so I have a Swiss passport so I got
invited to play the Swiss Nationals in
tennis and I I won the Swiss Nationals
which throw surprised everybody
including myself you say that very
nonchalantly yeah I got invited and I
won what's the matter
and then they invited me to play tennis
for the the Swiss national tennis team
Davis Cup and all that
I was then 21 and I thought that was
much better than working in a bank and
so I I did that right I played Wimbledon
and Roland Garros and all the big
tournaments in Europe and Davis Cup and
like that meanwhile my family was sort
of wandering this guy just gonna play
tennis or is he gonna do something else
and eventually I I came back to Brazil
and started working but that was sort of
my my early start and I know go ahead
yeah and then and then when I came back
to Brazil I I joined all these Ivy
Leaguers guys from the Harvard Business
School Princeton and like that and who
would set up a finance company and I
thought you know it looked very good and
all of them graduated good ideally
schools and like that well the result of
that was we went broke in three years
that was a very traumatic experience so
you know crises are always there and you
learn something and every one of them
and hopefully you come out better and
you know in hindsight these are fun
stories because you know many of us know
where you ended up but at the time what
were you feeling where you was it like a
crisis of confidence we'll use like calm
now I'm not going to be able to make
something out of this or did it where
you
pretty you know how did you pick up the
pieces and say no I'm gonna keep working
on this and especially keep working in
finance oh I would yeah depressed for a
while huh you know I graduated from
Harvard I thought I thought it was
pretty good uh-huh I go broke at 26 et
cetera
having just gotten married like that was
not a good experience and by I was I was
invited by a few larger organizations to
go and work for them and by I I didn't
like that I like the liberty of being in
a smaller company being more of an older
like that so I I didn't join any of the
larger organizations and actually join a
small brokerage house in Brazil and and
then that it went reasonably well what I
really wanted to run my show I didn't
want to be part of somebody else's show
I'm like that so after a few years of
doing that I bought my own brokerage
company and and set up with what became
a successful investment bank later and
and what I don't went to anyways we have
I think my I think my plane tennis and
you know when you play tennis you don't
win all the sets or all the games you
lose and and so that sort of taught me
that if you don't do well you can do
better next time you can practice more
or you can figure things out better like
that so that's that's been with me all
my life I think always trying to be a to
do better and to learn from your
mistakes and boy do you learn a lot from
your mistakes no usually the time we
learn the most and there's two questions
from YouTube that I think are related to
this one March Ella Carter asked what
was your biggest lesson in life and from
YouTube Matt gray asks who is the most
influential person in your life so
you're going through this journey I'm
sure there's a lot of
ters there but i guess what advice would
you give to a young George Apollo or
someone like you who's you know in that
position now and then who are your
influencers who kind of got you kept you
on the on the trajectory well you know
when I learned that it took me a while
to learn I was a tennis player a surfer
and then went it's financial market and
was basically a trader and financial
market so all of those things basically
made me a short-term thinker
I didn't think very far ahead and only
with time and with some of the mistakes
I made then I learned that you know what
what's gonna happen 24 hours or in the
next week or next month it's not really
that important and you've got to figure
out where you're going for a longer
period of time and so as time went by my
my thinking became much more long-term
oriented and it took me a while to learn
that then you know it sort of clicked
and some of the things I began doing
when I was already 40 were getting close
to 50 we're really long-term ideas and
they actually turned out much better
than in my trading days when I was
thinking of the next week or 24 hours or
the things like that in terms of the
most influential person my father died
when I was 13 my mother was a very
strong personality yesterday was
Mother's Day so I thought a lot about
her and she was very influential very
strong personality I only had a sister
who was 10 years older than me so I was
sort of like an only son and my mother
and I were very close and she was very
ambitious for me
very loving also but gave me a lot of
Liberty she trusted me in child
I could sort of go out and do anything I
wanted on my own and that helped me a
lot and figuring going through
experiences where which were not
necessarily always good or like that but
I think the Liberty she gave me and the
love she showed in backing me up was
very important in everything else that I
was able to do later know that's super
powerful and and you know now you
mentioned that long-term thinking which
I agree with you you don't see enough of
it and I I'm guessing you pinpoint that
as one of your differentiators and what
allowed you to do do well you know
putting that same hat on later in life
you've become very active in
philanthropy and that's how we connected
almost almost ten years ago now eight
nine ten years ago what got you so
active in philanthropy you know a lot of
ways for those of you those who don't
know you're one of the most active
philanthropists in Brazil especially
with the focus on education what got you
interested in in this problem when I was
building up our brokerage company in
Brazil I had no competitive advantage in
terms of having a name or having money
and I figured out that the only way I
could really be competitive would be if
I hired and attracted the best possible
people to work with me so I made a big
effort in looking for these people I
would interview hundreds of candidates
per year and picked the best even when
we were hiring 10 or 15 people per year
that became very important for us in
building up the brokerage business and
in doing that I met a lot of really
spectacular people who had not had the
proper education or have not been
trained properly and like that they were
pretty exceptional and so I figured that
besides trying to improve people who
were working with me and making good
them a better education maybe I could do
it for other people so I set up these
foundations which basically give
scholarships to people who want to study
abroad at that point there was very few
scholarships for people wanting to study
abroad and so this the foundation which
was called hold ourselves to that and
our self-study
became quite important and over the
years we sent many Brazilians to u.s.
colleges and they've come back to Brazil
they've built businesses up lately I've
been giving a lot of scholarships to
people who want to come back and go into
public service or to government I
figured we got enough good businessman
and we need better people in in
government and in the public sector so
that's how I sort of got going in terms
of trying to get people more educated or
give them worthwhile experiences by
studying abroad and and then we evolved
from that we evolved tried to improve
education in Brazil in general Brazil
scores very badly in all the
international tests and we should do
better I'm a big believer that countries
do as well as they have educated their
people so for Brazil to do well in the
future we have to educate more people
and educate them better so my foundation
now beyond giving scholarships to people
wanting to study abroad we have teacher
training courses we work in partnership
with you so that people can learn more
online we try to work with governments
in terms of improving their teaching
standards like that we give courses to
school principal so that they can manage
the school's better
and we make a variety of efforts
recently there is one small city in
Brazil called slow brow it's a very poor
city in the Northeast but for the last
10 years it has scored really high in
the national test of how public schools
are doing and we have now hired some of
the people that set up the system in the
city of 200,000 people and we're trying
to duplicate what they have done in
other small cities of less than 200,000
and it's much easier to introduce
education systems in small cities than
in big cities so something very
practical they were successful and we're
now in another 25 cities and if that
works we will duplicate it to 50 cities
so we have a lot of things going on
besides what we do with the cat Academy
which I think is really important I
think you know online learning has a big
future in Brazil and in poor countries I
think being able to access online
learning in poor countries is really
very more important because it gives you
a chance to to reach the people who
really don't have a chance to go to
school or have access to terrific
teachers or like that so anyway that's
what all I do is a little drop in the
bucket of what Brazil needs to improve
education but I you know I'm trying I'm
trying to do my best
no well I think I think you're being a
slightly modest there but you know
there's a question that from YouTube
that Susanna Garcia Dominguez is asking
and this is actually something I've
always wondered actually how did you
learn about Khan Academy how did it show
up on your radar because you were one of
the earliest philanthropists to really
reach out to us I mean this was back in
2010 or 2011 we we were we were reading
about the count Academy and I said gosh
this makes so much sense
relative things that you had written in
the world that you had spoken and I
thought it made so much sense and you
know so I guess we tried to establish
some contact with you and then what
happened was the president of Brazil
called me up once and said you know this
guy Sal Khan I think he's very
interesting can you get him to come to
Brazil I said I don't know but I can try
and so we actually we were already
talking but then we shits out don't you
want to come down here the president
Brazil wants to talk to you and so you
came down and you know and talked to the
president like that and I got to know
you a little bit better and and that's
how we sort of got going no I I tell
this story a lot it's actually those
early days I mean for those who don't
know I mean back in 2010 I think Khan
Academy was about an eighth person
organization we were above a Chinese tea
store in downtown Mountain View here and
it might seem I I have an extroverted
nature but I'm actually very introverted
so I really enjoy kind of being by
myself and I think I was recording a
video or something and someone said hey
you know we have this delegation from
Brazil that is here and I was like oh
but I need to finish this video and I
was kind of in a grumpy mood somebody
couldn't finish like an organic
chemistry video or something and then we
met and I remember that room it was like
there was like 12 of us packed into a
room that could probably fit five people
but who would have thought I remember
y'all you know we were very intrigued by
the notion of being able to work in
Brazil but it it felt it felt like we
were small at that point but y'all were
really pulling us in and I have to say
if not for that push then and then
obviously we started working together
over the next few years I don't think
you know now Khan Academy in Brazil is
the most built-out Khan Academy outside
of the United States and it wouldn't it
wouldn't be if not because of that first
meeting in y'all's desire so and y'all
have been supporters not just in Brazil
but you know Khan Academy globally so
that was one of those meetings that
definitely have been logged in my memory
bank
and obviously you had a wonderful
wonderful trip to to Brazil well one
question you know from YouTube actually
there's two questions I think they're
related Jozy Mubarak asks what advice
would you give to graduates and wouldn't
it related that Nikhil Govan they're
asked how do you build great leadership
skills and I'll add to that you
mentioned like you realize the success
of your org for hiring the right people
and maybe training the right people how
what do you look for like are there are
there other signs that you see in young
people that you say hey that person is
is on to something this is a person I
want to invest in and work with and
there's other signs you see in people
like ah not so sure I think I'll pass on
them I don't think there's anything very
special the way we went about hiring
people and you know we first thing I I
learned or I learned in my ideally
partnership which didn't work out is to
run a business or to run anything you
have to have different types so you if
everybody's the same it won't work very
well so you know I made an effort to
having different points of view and we
like people who get things done people
who work as a team but also you know
will individually try to get things
moving or going we we don't tolerate bad
ethics at all I mean there are some
people who are brilliant but their
ethics aren't good and and if you know
that doesn't work in an organization so
if there's any sign of ethical
misbehavior like that we don't tolerate
it and basically we we like giving
people experiences that they to test
them and the ones that do well we
promote very fast the ones that don't do
well stay behind that's right so you
know you know organizations now we have
over 200,000 employees sort of
we always know who our who is on a fast
track every organization of ours on a
yearly basis looks at everybody who's on
a fast track and figures out what they
should be doing for these people so
we're always trying to pick the
exceptional ones and giving them a
chance to do something bigger and so
that's that's how how it has basically
worked you know I I think like I say you
learn a lot from your mistakes so I'm
talking about what worked well and maybe
I should talk a little bit about what
didn't work well over the last five
years our companies have not done as
well as they did the first 25 years like
that so like I said we've always been
very people focused and always focused
on people who are ambitious why I get
things done cut cost look at look at
goals and have very clear goals unlike
that we missed down a little bit in
terms of the world becoming much more
consumer centric in terms of the clients
and public having much more many more
choices of what they want to consume or
basically a consumer goods businesses so
we didn't pay enough attention to to
what our buyers or what our clients
really wanted and at the same time we
did not use what is in available
nowadays in terms of artificial
intelligence to know more about our
clients and where they are and what they
want and like that and our culture was a
culture very much we got to reach the
goals we got to produce more we got to
produce cheaply and like that but we
missed out a little bit
on what the client really wants and
figuring out what he really wants with
the mother techniques which are
available so we're catching up now we're
going in that direction but uh you know
you have to have good people and you
have to have good people who are for
up-to-date on what is going on in the
world and we didn't have enough of those
because our culture was so successful
and doing so well for a while that it
took us a little while to realize that
we had to go in this direction and for
those of y'all who are watching and you
know George Apollo I think very
intentionally keeps a fairly low profile
but some of these organizations include
things like InBev and you know an Heiser
Bush Burger King so very very large
global brands that that folks might be
familiar with I mean given your lens on
global on the global economy but
especially the Brazilian economy what's
your sense of the short and long term
economic implications of the crisis
we're going through oh I think it's like
I should not be to various crises and
this one looks like it's gonna last
longer and it's it's it's gonna be tough
on the emerging markets because the
emerging markets really lack the
organization to figure out who is sick
who isn't sick what to do about it
emerging markets have slums people
living very close to one another it's
very difficult to have lock down the
people need to make money many of these
people and the slums are sellers in the
streets unlike that they're not able to
go out now so they can't sell any
they're desperate to get out there
itself it's going to be Messier in the
emerging markets than the more developed
countries which is very sad
and I think it will take a little a
little while longer than most people in
the stock market or financial markets
think that it will take you know many
people think Oh three or four months
from now think we'll start moving again
but it yeah they may start moving but it
will take a lot longer to things really
falling to fall in place again and so
what advice you know we have so many
young people watching and we have a lot
of questions I haven't gotten to
anywhere close to the even of the
majority of them but there's so many
young people who are always uncertain
about their future what should I do and
there's a lot of questions about your
life and a lot of interest there but
especially in a time of uncertainty like
this what advice would you have for them
don't give up hang on things look pretty
bad you sort of think the world is
coming to an end or earrings coming to
an end well you know eventually they
sort of write themselves and there are
many opportunities in crises I'm not
only talking about financial
opportunities but there are a lot of
opportunities to learn to learn
different things to do things in a
different way to think in a different
way so you know I think about it think
about how you can adapt and what you
really want to make out of your life and
how this crisis can perhaps help you in
achieve what you want to achieve well
that's great advice well you know I just
want to thank you George Apollo for I
don't think I've ever had a chance to do
it but I'll do it in a very public
setting Khan Academy would not exist in
the way it does today if not for your
support and your foundation support and
it for sure would not exist in the way
it exists in Brazil if not you're you're
kind of you know really pushing that in
a very very early stage so so thank you
and I I agree with everything you said
it's gonna be interesting times next few
months years but there's problems to be
solved and we look forward to partnering
with you and your team to get that
solved so thank you so much for being
part of this
Thank You Sal and it's been a real
pleasure to work with your organization
over the years we have a feeling that
we're getting something done or
improving things in Brazil so and the
world so let's keep working and we'll
have a better world sounds good to me
thank you so much bye-bye bye thank you
and so thanks everyone for joining as
you can see we're you know I feel lucky
I've said multiple times I feel very
fortunate to have the role I have
obviously I like to geek out on academic
stuff and work with our team here at
Khan Academy making the product better
making the experience better but another
joy of this job is being able to have
really amazing partners like George
Apollo who I consider a mentor who
pushed us to do more things who allow
frankly a lot of what we do to be
possible so you know I think I get
disproportionate credit for the work at
Khan Academy it's a team of 200
full-time folks thousands of volunteers
hundreds of thousands of folks many of
you donate and many really great
partners like George Apollo and his team
so with that thank you for joining this
livestream and I look forward to seeing
all of you all tomorrow have a good
night afternoon day
you